back
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
go ahead
doubt me if you'd like
I said
when Merrick Garland appointed a special
counsel to investigate
the the documents
at Joe Biden's residence in his office
at the Penn Biden Center
that the Republicans would lose their
narrative
I said it and this is good it's a good
thing
people should not be mad at garlands
people should not be mad at the process
people should stay fast that Joe Biden
did not
steal classified documents to cover up a
coup attempt for sure
and yesterday the news broke as we were
on the air
we talked about it a bit at the end
at the former vice president Mike Pence
had documents at his home with
classified markings I don't know if he
put him there on or the fly put him
there
the point is is that they were there
and the Republicans this morning are
scrambling for the difference
between Apples and the orange they're
scrambling for the difference between
Apples and the orange
they're really trying hard not to throw
Mike Pence under the bus they're really
trying hard to protect their criminal
Jesus
Grandpa poopy pants the Cheeto dust q
and honor down at Mar-A-Lago
but they're having a difficult time this
morning
there's one one thing and I want to
predict this now out in the open on the
air again time stamp the [__] cut it out
make me a liar but doubt me on this
the one thing that the Republicans are
trying to do this morning is the fact
that Joe Biden had documents that were
had classified markings from when he was
a United States Senator here's the
problem that they're going to have with
this is these United States senators
setting Republican United States
senators better not
better not have any documents where
they're not supposed to be with any
classified markings on them
they will
they will folks they will they're gonna
they're gun doubt me they're gonna find
sitting United States senators Ted Cruz
they're gonna find these [__]
chuckleheads
with documents with classified markings
whichever whatever level it's supposed
to be top secret National Security
documents are just a simple classified
Market
they're gonna find them where they're
not supposed to be with these United
States senators
and Republicans are going to have to now
answer trust me on this this is going to
happen are going to have to answer what
you said you said the reason why the
Biden case is so bad is because he was a
Senator and here are you not setting
United States senators
with documents where they're not
supposed to be trust me on this
their narrative is smashed into pieces
and the reason why is because these are
not even on the same universe on the
same planet in the same galaxy folks the
only thing that makes these stories at
all similar
is Pence Biden and Trump we're all in
the executive branch and they have
documents that have markings on them
where they're not supposed to be that's
the only thing that ties them together
the thing that makes the Trump case
Stand Out is the Criminal Intent and the
criminal obstruction that is the re hey
at least stefanik the reason why the FBI
got a bench warrant from a [__]
federal judge to search and seizure of
his residence at Mar-A-Lago for our
documents is because his Criminal Intent
and his criminal obstruction you [__]
dummy
I'm talking to Elise devonic if she can
hear me you're a [__] dummy
they know this though they know the
difference they know their narratives
and trouble folks
their narrative is on the run and this
idea that somehow Biden oh Biden's
popularity is gonna go down because who
gives a rat's ass
who gives a [__]
if Joe Biden's popularity goes down to
based on how they handled it folks
they thought that the Afghanistan
debacle that Trump created for Biden
would be the nail in the coffin for
their Red Wave in November of 2022 and
it didn't happen
who gives a [__] [__] about some
stupid ass poll
of people who may or may not give a [__]
about the differences between these
documents cases no one gives a [__]
about your stupid [__] pole and the
media buys this [__] every time Hook
Line Sinker with this dumb [__]
have you ever
have you ever heard me
this is great Paul look at this pole oh
my God I can't believe this pole oh man
this pole must be dead at you [__] that
[__]
the polls suck okay don't listen to the
poll
don't the media is trying to get polls
out there so you'll buy their narrative
the media that oh this bad case boys
it's a some [__] oh my God it's gonna
destroy him wait until we we wait till
Friday when we drop another reality TV
story on this document's case that makes
not a hell of beans worth of difference
to your daily lives Listen People
don't give a [__]
if government officials have access to
classified documents that's actually how
it's supposed to work
they do give a [__] if you have Criminal
Intent that you're stealing our
documents to cover up a coup attempt to
overthrow our vote and to take away our
country I think they care about that
they don't give a [__]
if Mike Pence are are Joe Biden
inadvertently had documents that were
marked classified a handful of them not
thousands a dozen okay they don't give a
[__] it doesn't affect their price of
eggs it doesn't affect the price of milk
it doesn't affect the price of gasoline
Jim Jordan and it definitely doesn't
take away your gas stoves or your
[__] M MS
so or your Xbox now Xbox is woke because
you know they have a feature on the Xbox
that make sure you don't have to pay as
much to run the thing
when you're burning electricity
because that's woke now that you don't
want to pay as much on your utility bill
what the [__] what the [__] is wrong
with these people
foreign
speaking of that I think I think A and W
root beer was watching our show the
other day I think a lot of people Joe
Scarborough had been watching my show
the last couple weeks too
I don't know if you guys know this but
we are way ahead of the curve on the
national narrative and and what is real
and what is not here on the Tony
Michaels podcast I don't know if you've
noticed that
but if you haven't stick around you're
gonna see that
you're gonna see it play out time and
time again because I don't [__] you
I don't [__] give you fancy polls and
fancy studies and try to determine why
this is bad for Joe Biden I don't give a
[__] what is bad for Joe Biden what is
good for him I don't give a [__]
the only thing I care about
and that you should care about is our
[__] democracy right now that is that
is at the top of the list these people
are trying to steal it away from you
the possibility of you having our
Republic and participating in it that's
what they're trying to steal away from
you with this nonsense about [__] M
M's and gas stoves and gas prices and
how it's all Joe Biden's fault and Joe
Biden's a criminal because he had a
document Mark classified and Hunter
Biden laptop I don't know
I I can't make it make sense I I I can't
I can mock it but I can't make it make
sense they they it doesn't make any
sense trust me no matter how you sniff
it out no matter how you order it it's
not gonna [__] make sense they're
they're delusion and their their ability
to mind [__] their constituents does not
make sense folks
but what I can do is I can just give it
to you real and raw
just tell you the [__] way it is
I've been watching American politics for
over 20 years now
I told you yesterday that if you've been
paying attention for the last 15 years
really paying attention you know that
Donald Trump is going to be their
nominee
they're gonna do it they're gonna do it
doubt me
even if he's indicted I don't give a
[__] what charges and how many they're
gonna make him
their nominee
you don't have to go very far to realize
that that's going to be the case
Paul Ryan doesn't want to be nominee
Mitch McConnell
like on and on it goes with anyone who
hates Trump but they won't say they
won't not vote for him if he's the
nominee because they know he's gonna be
they know it
yesterday we we talked about Ron
DeSantis
he's working really hard to be more
Hitler than Trump so he can be the
nominee but
yeah I think Ron DeSantis is is young
enough he'll punt to 2028.
Andy won't have Joe Biden
uh to contend with yeah that's right Joe
Biden is going to be a he's going to be
a force to be reckoned with as much as
he's done for the American people
and I don't I don't I don't I don't give
Joe Biden a lot of compliments I don't
even talk about him a lot on here
because you don't I don't need to I
don't need to tell you
the good [__] that Joe Biden's done for
our country I don't need to tell you
that the proof's in the pudding
I mean I'll point out the Republicans
hypocrisy on his achievements like when
they when the Democrats and the Joe
Biden and Joe Biden White House pass
infrastructure
one of the biggest infrastructure
packages America's ever seen
one that is going to bring more
information to rule American than they
could ever imagine with high-speed
internet
that that's one of the biggest
advancements and investments in our
country folks and I know it feels like
oh my God these hillbillies are going to
have access to the internet now yeah
that's not a bad thing the internet is a
scary place
but it's also the the key the key to
pushing a national narrative and
National message why do you think why do
you think these these [__] rule dummy
white people believe this stupid [__]
they don't have access to any other
information in the ship that's being
pumped into their brains into their
minds being mind [__] on AM radio
through through right wing talk radio
still
there's no left-wing talk radio on AM
stations and and bump [__] who knows
where
no there's not
there's not there won't be so it's a
great investment and the best part is
Republicans love to take love to take
credit for it Rhonda santis running
around the state with big checks uh my
state Mike Parsons taken all the credit
for all the infrastructure
that the lip guards the Communists the
marxists
got done and and did for our country and
the American people now we point out
that hypocrisy that's what you do
you mock these people
just like we can mock the fact
that anyone
Elise stephanic Ted Cruz or any other
Republican that gets in front of a
microphone over the next few days and
over the weekend trying to figure out a
way to tell you how the Mike Pence
document thing is completely different
than the Joe Biden and Donald Trump's
than Joe Biden and Joe Biden is a
criminal because Hunter Biden's laptop
that I'm dead serious that's that's the
roundabout thing that they're gonna do
it's really stupid it doesn't make sense
and that's why they're in trouble with
this narrative
that's why they're in trouble I don't
know if uh appointing the special
counsel was a political move
I have no idea I really don't give a
[__] to be quite honest with you I don't
know if if Joe Biden called up Merrick
Garland said hey appoint a special
counsel for me too please
it's going to be good politically
because if he did that was brilliant
it was brilliant
as the doj
um investigates this these Mike Pence
documents that we found and honestly
folks I actually don't believe there's
anything nefarious with the Mike Pence
documents at this point there's no
evidence of that whatsoever not even
close to that whatsoever as soon as they
found them as soon as his attorneys
found them they turned them over to the
FBI immediately
um I would guess that Mike Pence is
gonna have the doj and the FBI come to a
search of his home just like Joe Biden
has done because Joe Biden did it I
would imagine that's what's going to
happen I would I would imagine if
anything nefarious it smells funny at
all that Merrick Garland is either going
to get her who is this current special
counselor for the Biden's documents case
to look at this case or get a different
special counsel to look at this case
I think that's in the cards too
but I really do not believe there is no
evidence not a single shred at this
point that Mike Pence has obstructed
Justice Mike Pence has stolen these with
some kind of Criminal Intent not a thing
trust me if Mike Pence stole these with
Criminal Intent he would not be inviting
people to come get them and to
investigate it wouldn't be doing that
that's not that's not that's not what
criminals do see criminals what happens
is when a criminal steals our [__]
documents to either sell destroy or
cover up a coup and they take thousands
and thousands of those documents to
their private home
which is an apartment in a bum ass Golf
Course down in South Florida when they
take those documents and they have
people like Kyle Rittenhouse Marjorie
Taylor green and Lauren bobert in the
same room as top secret Doctor Who's
probably showing them to them bragging
about it probably selling documents to
Saudi Arabia destroying documents
burying them into your ex-wife's casket
to cover up a coup attempt and your
obstruction with Russia there's another
thing we learned about the last few days
and then when the justice department and
Nara wants their [__] back you say no
and then you lie about it and you
obstruct and now you've committed
another crime see that's the thing
that's the thing that really has these
[__] America First Nazis in a pickle
here with these documents is Trump has
Criminal Intent and criminal obstruction
that is how and why the FBI got a bench
warrant to go search his [__] house
for the crimes that he committed
that is what the difference is is the
Criminal Intent and the criminal
obstruction I've been saying it from the
[__] beginning when we found out
about Joe Biden had documents next to
his Corvette oh my God he had a
classified marked document next his
Corvette and and again most of the
American people don't even under I don't
even fully understand the classification
markings on documents
um one example that we have of
classified markings is that is the email
lady you remember the email lady when
when James Comey and the FBI
investigated the [__] out of her over
nothing over emails that she was
planning her daughter's wedding and it
happened just so happened that one one
email had a small classified marking and
after the fact of it having classified
Market they changed the classified
classification where it shouldn't have
the marking
that is in the cards in these documents
it is possible that these documents have
classified markings but were
reclassified after the fact
the best part about the chain of custody
of documents
is they will know the chain of custody
of documents more than likely and they
will be able to that's what the doj is
doing in the Biden's case now trying to
figure out if there wasn't tent
and if there was obstruction there's not
there is no obstruction no stretching no
collusion
no obstruction no collusion
Joe Biden nor Mike Pence stole documents
from our government
to cover up a coup attempt
and I know because Mike Pence didn't
participate ultimately at the end of the
day in the coup attempt that's why they
wanted to hang him that's why Donald
Trump wanted his supporters to hang him
because he wouldn't do what he wanted to
do which was
steal our vote steal our election steal
our democracy [__] on our constitution
that's what Trump wanted Pence to do so
I highly doubt
I highly doubt less evidence shows
different
that there's something nefarious about
the documents that probably
inadvertently ended up at Mike Pence's
residence that have classified markings
on it
now let's get to the Russian collusion
because I think this is
I think this is a funny story how uh
Hillary Clinton the email lady was right
was right the whole time
about almost I don't know everything
everything
this [__] FBI official that has been
arrested and charged with money
laundering money laundering
oligarapaska's money at Russian R
laguarc it is it seems I don't know it
seems kind of weird that this is the
same FBI official
who said before the 2016 election that
there was no collusion between Russia
and Trump and then and then for some odd
reason he went on to launder money and
work for darapaska after he retired from
the FBI just a few years later seems
kind of suss I don't know just a little
I wonder I wonder if he's a corrupt
piece of deep State [__]
that's right I'm gonna start using the
Deep state folks it works we're going to
use that language if you're not using
that language already you need to the
Trump deep State that's what this guy is
he's the Trump deep state
he was placed in that position to make
sure
that they sold America a lie
and he was placed in our government for
that purpose
now rather Jim Comey willingly or
unwinningly
placed him in that position to make
those statements doesn't matter he was
placed there and he made those
statements
and he said there was no collusion
between Trump and Russia and there is
because he's part of it
they're always projecting folks always
every single time
every single
time
they project
we watched as the Cheeto dust mobster oh
excuse me cueing on her see I went back
to my old roots see I used to call him
the Cheeto dust mobster right
and then it was obvious that he's not a
very good mobster
it's obvious and then he kind of got
back on the Q Anon train so I changed
his nickname officially
from the Cheeto dust mobster to the
Cheeto dusk q and honor I think it's
more appropriate really don't you I
think it is now I'm I probably will
never change
his follow-up nickname which is Grandpa
Poopypants because that is always fit
perfectly and it will continue I'm sure
but the Cheeto dusk q and honor posting
statements about the perfect phone call
in Georgia he's telling on himself he's
telling on himself foreign
play out as we watch
this FBI agent now here's here's what
I'll say about this NBI agent
um at first glance when I first started
to read the story I thought oh this
guy's gonna flip
he's not gonna flip
he's not gonna flip he won't flip nope
don't count on it not gonna do it
he's indicted on totally separate
charges from the collusion case when it
comes to Donald Trump and collusion
and and the 2016 election that's a it's
a totally separate issue it's a totally
separate indictment he's not going to
flip he won't
don't expect any other thing than this
guy to go to court
in front of a jury in a trial to be
convicted on his charges and serve a
prison sentence for Trump
for Trump because all he'd have to do is
turn and he wouldn't have as much of a
prison sentence this guy's former law
enforcement he's a former fed he would
get plenty plenty of preferential
treatment
plenty he's an old white dude plenty a
preferential treatment I'm sure of it
but he's not going to do it he's going
to go to prison for Donald Trump it's
gonna happen
there's going to be a lot of there's
already a lot of people in prison right
now as we speak
right now as we speak as we sit here
there's a lot of people in prison
on behalf of Donald Trump
think about that think about the history
here
when we look back 20 30 years from now
we count how many people actually went
to prison for this fool
and and in 20 30 years from now we will
know the full truth and nothing but the
truth
about this idiot and you won't be able
to deny I mean you'll be able to deny it
but you'll look like a [__] fool I
mean you think they look like fools now
wait 20 30 years from now
when they really look like fools when
they really have egg on their face
if they're still supporting this
bonehead
thousands of people are gonna go to
prison for this fool
and this FBI agent is one of them he's
not going to flip
not on Trump not on the team Trump nope
not gonna do it
he's going to go to trial he's going to
take his he's going to take his blows
and he'll go to prison for quite some
time
that's what he's gonna do
I don't know what he has over him I
don't know how he does it I don't know I
don't know what the delusion is or the
the incentive is to be mind [__]
and to believe that this guy is some
kind of Jesus or God I I don't know I
don't know it's it's not for us to
figure out it's only for us to Mock and
to protect our democracy from that's it
that's our job our job is not to figure
it out our job is to protect our
democracy from it and the best way you
can do that is come here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific because I
will give you the tools that you need I
will give you the Canon fodder that you
need for the national message and
National narrative I've been at the
minute Merrick Garland we played it here
live on this show when Merrick Garland
announced the special counsel for the
Biden documents I said immediately that
it's a good thing that the right is
going to lose their narrative it's going
to be stripped away from them they won't
be able to contain it and they haven't
and it's going to get worse for them
good [__] them we'll point it out here
on the Tony Michaels podcast live
two hours a day on YouTube Twitter and
twitch and simulcasting from the Midas
touch Facebook page do not forget to go
to the YouTube page and subscribe go to
the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube
subscribe there we're trying to get to
20 000. also follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod
and download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google your favorite
directory make sure to leave us a great
review while you're subscribing there if
you're on Facebook right now come over
and follow my page at the Joni Michaels
and if you haven't already download the
Twitch app it's free
the Twitch app is free soon we're
changing some things over at twitch for
those of you listening on Twitch
um we're changing some things over there
um so uh because of membership and
monetizing the twitch channel uh we
become an affiliate so uh and I think
we're almost a partner or something I'm
not sure what it all means to be quite
honest with you but I think over on
Twitch if you have a Prime Membership
you get one free subscription I think if
you sign in with your Prime account you
can actually get a subscription and
you'll be able to watch it ad free I'm
not sure when this the ads are going to
start over on Twitch I have no idea
again I'm still trying to figure out
twitch but the Twitch app is free you
can watch it there and you can you'll be
able to subscribe soon
um and use your Prime account to get one
free subscription you can use it on us
or someone else and you'll be able to
answer watch it ad free but it is going
to be monetized over there so we're
going to start to have some commercials
during the show but I gotta figure it
all that out I'm not I'm not exactly
sure exactly how twitch works I'm still
working on it
but I'll let you know here on the air as
that continues and also I want to thank
everyone who has shown support at
patreon patreon I think patreon uh you
just go to the Tony michaels.com and you
can you can sign up for the patreon
account for a support here at the show
you can support me again at patreon.com
the Tony Michaels or again just go to
the Tony michaels.com
the link is at the top of the page or
you can give in the tip jar now patreon
is kind of a a monthly thing I don't
know if you guys know what it is it
helps support the show you give 5 10 or
20 dollars you get different things for
each level
um and there's a fifty thousand dollar
level on there too
go check that out go see um
hi hey if someone's gonna pay me 50 000
a month to shut up I just might I mean I
got it on patreon so I guess I will if
they did so I don't know if you if you
want me to shut up and you got 50 Grand
laying around you can be shut up for a
month I'll go take a vacation
but to go check out patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or go to the Tony michaels.com
and hit the patreon button come join us
over there everyone stick around
I got plenty of clips
plenty of clips of these Republicans
losing their narrative on the documents
case Trump is in trouble on this trust
me he's in big trouble because their
narrative is stripping away from them
once again because they're boneheads
morons moglodytes the America First Nazi
party is on the run and we're chasing
them everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[__] them Buckle [__] em [__] em [__] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
hump day hump day off day it's Wednesday
January 25th
holy [__] anyways almost over
God damn do you see how time flies do
you see why we can't load up do you see
why we can't relent against these
America versus Nazis we have to stay
fast because time is slipping away
to protect our democracy
from the America First Nazis we watched
yesterday uh some clips of Ron DeSantis
being an absolute scumbag which I I
don't know if there's clips of him not
being a scumbag if you can find a clip
out there if Governor Ron DeSantis not
being his scumbag why don't you send it
to me I I want to see this I want to see
if he actually can get in front of a
camera and not be a total [__] bio
piece of garbage I doubt it but I want
to see it if it exists I would welcome
it I'll play it on the show and talk
about wow there's a 30 second glimp of
him not being a pile of [__]
I doubt it exists but good luck you can
send it to me I'll I promise if it if it
exists to uh play it
probably not we got a lot of Clips today
of
um
these Republicans and I'm gonna kind of
leave that because I got some more
stories that I want to talk about one of
them one of them goes back
one of them goes back to the Eminem
story
you remember the other day I think it
was on Monday we did like an hour and a
half on [__] Eminem's because Eminem
put out a statement that morning the
left bought it the right bought it they
bought into it it's all a [__] it's
all a ploy for a Super Bowl commercial
right we explained it in detail long
form detail on Monday and if you missed
it I don't know just just go subscribe
to the YouTube channel
and go watch Monday's show man that that
thumbnail is has Eminem's on it I forget
the exact name of the uh the title of
the episode but you'll find it just go
to the full episodes playlist on our
YouTube channel make sure to subscribe
while you're there and you can go watch
a two-hour show on why the m m stuff is
all [__] fake and it's phony and it's
just to bait the right and the left
bought it too in the meantime that's
just what happened
but this morning uh a w root beer
decided to jump on the bandwagon and I
guess I guess the um the right wing is
starting to buy this story now I'm sure
the left is much more skeptical because
this one
is very apparent that it's satire and
parody of the a w root beer now but they
obviously caught on and maybe they're
watching the show
maybe a W's marketing team is watching
the show and they're like hey this is a
great idea Mars has got the idea Tony's
telling us exactly laying out exactly
how this would work for marketing how
you bait the right wing get them to do
the long form
free advertising commercials marketing
and maybe they listen and maybe they
they caught the hint
but apparently the right did not uh
catch the hint and I guess they're
buying into it so maybe maybe we'll get
into that story today but uh in the
shitless Roundup I have a couple Clips I
want to show you because yesterday we
talked
um about Ron DeSantis that piece of [__]
oh you know what while I'm speaking
around DeSantis go to
store.donymichaels.com that store that
the attorneymichaels.com you can get all
your Rhonda santis can go [__] himself
merch there at store not the Tony
michaels.com it's one of our most
popular shirts honestly why wouldn't it
be when you can walk around saying
Rhonda santis can go [__] himself on a
personal billboard they're right on your
chest so go check out store.the Tony
michaels.com and grab all your Rhonda
santis can go [__] himself merch
I I love that design I did it myself and
to be quite honest I I came up with that
it's a great design probably the best
one I've ever made uh myself now Gabe
has done several of them we've we've
farmed out several the designs like the
Dank Brandon and the dark Brandon we
hired an artist to do that for us
worked out great
um you guys really like those
um and we've we've done other versions
of this of the merch but the Ronda
Sanders can go [__] himself something I
I don't know it's kind of like my baby I
guess because I I designed that one
myself so go check out
store.donymichaels.com and check out all
the merch designs but the um Rhonda
Santas can go [__] itself I got a coffee
mug with it on it
um and the coffee tastes really good out
of it for some reason I'm not really
sure what the effect is
um but when you Sip Coffee out of a mug
that says Rhonda Santos can go [__]
himself
it tastes better so here's what we're
gonna do I'm gonna play a few clips for
you some from Fox News and some from
some other Trader TV News Network of
um these um oh what is it the mothers of
Liberty or the the traders of oh yeah
moms of live moms of of Traders
we're gonna watch that
um
it's crazy [__] I I mean
can't be more overtly racist than this
but we're gonna watch it on the shitless
Roundup
where we round up all the Tweety tweets
and trendy Trends so let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the [__] list
welcome back to the Tony Michaels
podcast you have reached the segment
where we round up all the Tweety tweets
and trendy trends of the day we caught
the [__] list Roundup I think we should
probably Rebrand this thing
and I mean
well maybe not Twitter is more of a [__]
list now than ever
but have you noticed it's really hard to
get the [__] you want out of it it's
almost like
it's almost like Elon Musk paid 44
billion dollars for this platform to
absolutely ruin it with a white
right-wing fodder
and to mind [__] people on the internet
even more it's almost seems like that I
guess
um the Cheeto dust q and honor Grandpa
Poopypants has considered a banding
fraud social which will totally destroy
his own social media platform that's the
only reason why it exists in the first
place is for him to act like he's
tweeting
and apparently he's gonna he's
desperately begging Facebook to give him
his access back to Facebook so he can
post on Facebook and he's planning on
coming back to Twitter which I welcome
most people like oh my god oh what's
gonna happen the World's Gonna burn no
he's posting over there now
this will only make it more apparent of
how [__] deranged this idiot is
so I welcome him back on Twitter
sunlight is the best disinfectant let's
disinfect this [__] disease
that is Donald Trump on our country
and the disease that comes with it this
Maga [__] make America great again
America First we're America First Nazis
and we like it
doubt me on this
um here's the clip Ron has it here but I
said they seem to be getting Dumber
which they are getting Dumber
I mean as every day Ticks by these
people get dumber and dumber and I mean
they're dumb as dog [__] anyways
but here is the moms of Liberty chapter
president
and she's praising Ron Des santis for
rejecting College Prep
there you go African-American history
everyone keeps calling it AP
African-American history again this is a
stupid thing and liberals do they come
up with [__] [__]
and make no sense just call it what it
is just say what the [__] this [__] is
stop having some kind of
God damn
phrase that isn't going to offend
anybody
if Ron DeSantis and this white
racist woman Karen is offended by the
words College Prep well then [__] him
[__] him
it is a college prep course this course
is taught to high school seniors not to
grade schoolers
and they're [__] it and they're
infuriated they're infuriated that this
course could possibly be
offered in Rural America listen
this is a college prep course we
explained it yesterday here live on the
air I took some college prep courses in
high school they were math as like in
algebra
and gay
it was I think it was actually called
college algebra at the time I think and
I got dual credit for it
but most the time these college prep
courses especially to get dual credit
which is most of the time the intent of
them
you have to have a institution that
gives you the Dual credit
so a college or a university
that has accreditation for the
curriculum
of African-American history okay it's
not complicated
and it's an elective course
these people are acting like they're
forcing
kindergartners and first graders
to learn College Prep African-American
history
that is not even close to what is
happening they're [__] Liars they're
[__] grifters and they're boneheads I
mean literally on this clip they're
showing small school-aged children
learning which is not the people who are
learning the college prep
African-American history see that's the
reason why
the reason why messaging and narrative
matters is because and and I'm going to
knock on Ron here because he calls it AP
African-American history in this tweet
it's not AP stop calling it that
stop being so goddamn correct you do not
have to be correct in everything that
you [__] say it doesn't have to be a
hundred percent if you call it College
Prep African-American history yeah it's
a little longer
but if you call it that that's what it
is
and if someone's like oh it's actually
AP advanced placement dummy [__] them
[__] them they can they can knock you
all they want they can go listen to tyt
and David packman for all I'd give a
[__] those [__] defeatists
that's all they are is defeatist if they
knock you because you call AP American
African-American history College Prep
American history if they knock you for
that they don't understand why you're
saying it
they don't get it this is this is the
problem that the Liberals in this
country have a problem with their
narrative infrastructure
they don't have one I'm trying to build
one
honestly that that's what this show is
about
is to build an infrastructure that gives
people a way to see a national narrative
in the light that everyone can take it
and translate it and go promote
democracy
and stop these fascists from taking over
our [__] society
by acting like
some some libtard somewhere is teaching
first graders College Prep
African-American history if you just
call it College Prep
African-American history
then they would have a tougher time
selling this stuff but they're not
calling it College Prep folks that's not
what they're calling it
don't call it what they call it stop
playing into their [__] hands with
the narrative and the messaging
stop doing it yes you got to type out a
few more characters and you got to say a
few more words
and yeah it might not be exactly correct
I don't give a [__]
advanced placement is much more
prestigious it's much more Elite who
gives a rat's ass
who gives a [__]
call it what it is that's like when I
went on and on and on about the bill
back better bill they kept trying to
make the bill back better Bill about edu
or about infrastructure it should have
been about education the whole time they
would have been better off calling the
build back better Bill the BBB the Big
Bird bill
if they would have sold that bill to the
American people and to the Democratic
socialists in this country that children
school-aged children would start school
at three instead of five and would have
got their lunch paid for and got two
years of free college oh [__] it would
have flown through
the [__] liberals in the Congress
wouldn't have stood in its way if that
was the national messaging there's no
way they could have stood in the way of
a bill that the country understood oh
yeah it's an education Bill and it gets
it gets children to start school at
three instead of five I want to give
them school lunch all the way through no
matter what your income no matter what
your age no matter where you're at you
get to eat you get nutrition who would
have thought we should give children
nutrition at school instead of making
them pay for it these aren't [__]
weird ideas these aren't radical ideas
to I don't know feed children are you
[__] me this is some kind of radical
idea that we should give children food
you people are a bunch of [__]
dummies stop being so goddamn correct
about [__] Gabe Sanchez I know you
probably agree with me on this uh most
of the time not all the time but most of
the time man [__] them kids yeah [__]
them
yeah whatever dude I don't care I want
to make the case here because um Ron has
this clip of this lady we're gonna watch
it here bonehead oh my God you talk
about racist racist [__] I mean just
overt racism because yesterday Rhonda
Santos was trying to typical rap racism
when we were watching these clips when
he was like uh no it has to do with
queer Theory it's Ace not the blacks
it's the gays that you should be
offended about Gabe Sanchez not the
blacks and let me tell you something
what the blacks should want I'm going to
tell you exactly what black people want
because I'm a white man and I get to say
that's what he was saying yesterday no
yeah no totally I mean like he again the
dude is so triggered
that he has to then deny the history of
a group of people who have been
marginalized for hundreds of years in
this country right because even last
night and I'll find you the clip of Fox
News where they're like
it's uh Jesse Waters goes oh yeah I
think I got it I think yeah yeah and
basically it was like up until the 60s
and 70s which was [__] Paramount
right Paramount critical crucial pivotal
to there's something happening there's
something that happened crazy it's
almost like there was a bill that was
passed right it's almost like we can go
back into a history book that the
fascists didn't [__] take out the
[__] take out the [__] that they want to
take out it's almost if yeah once you
get to the 60s and the 70s they're like
I don't know if we should cover that
right I don't open to the point that
they can remember they're like oh yeah
that was pretty bad we should not talk
about that and then I love the whole
well if you think if you think that
racism exists now you should have been
there before the 1960s before civil
rights and and and we've come a long way
we've come a long way since the 50s and
the 60s yet no [__] because we passed
the Civil Rights Act you dumb
[__] if we're not far enough
but we came we came this far because I
don't know we acknowledge the equality
and Equity of I don't know black people
in the South they didn't have to be
segregated they had the right to vote
now it's almost it's almost like it's
almost like when you give people their
equality and the equity of the rights
Liberty and freedom right even if it's
just kind of like kind of because that's
what they did in the Civil Rights they
kind of gave it because the Supreme
Court's kind of taken all the the
[__] some of the voters
even you've got even Clarence Thomas who
is a black man in an interracial
marriage and even though he himself yeah
I know even he himself I mean a real get
out situation if you ask me but he
himself looks at it this and and once
you know Roe v Wade was overturned he
was like yeah well you know maybe we
should consider looking at uh gay
marriage and uh or same-sex marriage and
also interracial marriage is like you're
in one what are you what are you doing
right now but obviously you know it's
the fascist it's and when people look oh
that'll never happen they're like yes
they [__] will you think you think uh
Clarence Thomas you know you remember
that movie Shallow Hal yeah when uh yeah
um Jack I think it's Jack Black right
yeah Jack Black and then Tony Robbins
yeah he he puts a spell on him or
something yeah he does like a little
like like a hypnotized thing hypnosis
and he basically yeah says he he sees
the inner beauty I I almost I almost bet
I almost bet you couldn't do that movie
today people are like oh I'm so offended
by this you're calling people ugly
you're shaming people no he's act it's
actually the exact opposite yeah because
at the end of the movie right you find
oh and sorry to spoil it for someone who
hasn't seen it like I don't know 20
years ago uh movie is an old [__]
yeah yeah it's pretty old I I want to
say early 2000s but yeah you know for
anyone who hasn't seen it you know
spoiler alert earmuffs cover your ears
uh he ends up with the girl that he
thought was skinny which was uh Gwyneth
Paltrow right but she played she played
the uh uh the the sh the shallow version
yeah yeah yeah of the character and then
what happens is that's the inner beauty
that he sees or that the thing that he
wants to see right and then realizes oh
beauty is everything and I should accept
her as is and he's in a relationship
with the woman that's the problem right
because beauty is not it's not always on
the outside right and more likely most
the time it's on the inside we're gonna
see that with these chuckleheads in this
video but I was pointing out that Ron is
playing into their hands and again I I
like Ronnie post a lot of Clips but um
Ron Hey man you're playing to their
hands when you call it AP
African-American studies that they're
using it and I'm gonna show you this
clip why how they're using that
narrative that you're being so correct
you have to be absolutely 100 positively
correct that it's AP African American
history right listen it's College Prep
courses say it say college prep
African-American history that's the
narrative you have to push you have to
tell these dummies what it is because
also if you throw that against you if
you throw out the acronym AP No One's
Gonna know that unless they've actually
taken advantage placement so No One's
Gonna know oh that's actually what it
means so yeah we should dumb it down
right for the national narrow in the
National message and the reason why is
because what this chucklehead does I
don't know what her name is
um I really don't give a [__] to be
quite honest with you I mean you can see
when I pause it here it says schools are
harming children with transgender
ideology
there is no transgender ideology that's
not a thing it's not a thing it's just
like um I don't know
um humans treating other humans decently
that's yeah it's almost like hey it's
almost like there was this uh rule um it
might have been uh golden uh in which
you want other people to treat you how
you would want to be treated like you
you should treat others oh how you want
to be treated right you learn that right
early on in your development are you
sure you're at school are you sure are
you sure that wasn't in the CR that that
sounds like CRT games I mean it could
have been great it's crazy that we would
ever respect other humans the way in
which you should as it is well it is
kind of it is kind of um it is kind of a
high bar for these people to treat other
people with decency I mean just look at
the ladies hat it says moms of Liberty
she clearly does not know what the word
Liberty means yeah also Liberty uh
what is she liberating what is she
[__] what is it what is this mother
liberating
what we try that children what the intro
says it every day here the the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
not
Liberty because you just go look up the
[__] definition of Liberty and you'll
understand that when you're when your
goal is to oppress the rights of other
people that Liberty is not the thing
you're doing yeah it's the opposite
that's not that's not it's not what you
think it is right it's the opposite just
because you're calling it Liberty
doesn't mean it is but this is this is
wildly racist
um I'm not surprised uh Sarah
yeah she's I guess she's like the um the
local chapter prison or some [__] and
they had a little chapter one chapter
right well whatever the hell mom's a
liberty is a bunch of [__] scumbags
they're the ones that that round that
got people to go from town to Town and
County to County uh during uh 2020 uh to
talk about the CRT and to push that
[__] story same same group of
[__] mom's a liberty
um
oh yeah yeah they're being oh they want
to ban the [__] books my friend yeah
they're for Liberty man they want to
have the Liberty Angel rights that's
right they want you to have the Liberty
to not read the books that you want to
read which is not Liberty it's listen
go look up the [__] word Liberty dust
off the old Websters on your shelf Tara
have it if they have it that's true well
you know maybe I mean I I have way too
high expectations for some of these
[__] well let's listen to how
she feels about Rhonda santis making
sure that kindergartners don't take a
class called College Prep I'm
African-American history which is not a
thing that exists it's it's not a thing
it's it's fake outrageous fake chaos but
let's listen to her racism if I you know
my parental rights are not being
expected there it is listening to us
we're a small County
Texas
and that we're also fighting the same
thing and I am so thankful so she didn't
even live in Florida
no that even in Florida but what does
this tell you what does this show you
because what is going to happen I
guarantee it doubt me doubt me
[__] I Mark the time stamp for
January 25th uh 12 54 uh Pacific time or
Eastern time Tony Michaels said that the
state of Texas
the governor of Texas and other red
states are going to follow Ron Hitler
DeSantis lead on this and they are going
to start Banning College Prep courses
for African-American studies well I
think didn't AP already come out and
they now have caved to making changes
well I mean you know I I guess I guess
they could make changes to this
curriculum but the point is is that it
doesn't matter AP African-American
college prep African-American
studies course rejected by Florida to be
revised says the College Board the
organization which oversees the advanced
placement program says it would release
the official framework of the course on
February 1st the first day of black
history month so it sounds like for
let's talk about how the people I mean
like you know I mentioned it yesterday
how let's talk about white flight let's
talk about redlining let's do all the
institutions let's talk about
cul-de-sacs God damn right let's do it
all but but this lady's in Texas and I
know what they're doing they're trying
to push this Nash again folks National
narrative that this scary this scary
this scary class is being taught to your
kindergartners watch on the screen what
happens during this clip watch the the
[__] just the vile [__] lies watch
people that uh Rhonda Santos is exposing
advanced placement program the AP
program has been woke for a while there
have been concerns with them already and
this agenda is being infiltrated into
Rural America there it is infiltrated
into Rural America meaning white people
are being forced
to learn about the actual history
of of the plight and the institutional
racism in this country of black
Americans and black folks in this
country and people of color for that
matter and all the while all the while
they have little school-aged children as
if they're studying yeah College Prep
African-American history in this clip
they aren't showing high school students
which it is taught to high school
students and college students well
because they're trying to say you know
schools are harming children children
it's got to save the children save the
children Tony well don't feed them don't
feed them but here are here are two
things right one is they're trying to
push the idea that it's innocent
children who are subjected to this
ideology and this course framework that
they can't say no to right they're
they're stuck in that school like a
prison one door in one door out just
like Ted Cruz wants
but also
it's important to remember that none of
the [__] people including this
territory pets pesh whatever the [__]
her name is she's a bigot but none of
the people who are complaining about AP
courses have ever taken an AP course and
if they have taken an AP course I
guarantee they never got above a [__]
two out of five on an AP exam well that
would that would assume that they prep
for college that they weren't handed
College to them on a silver platter or a
white platter whichever whatever color
you want uh maybe we should change the
narrative on that to a white bladder
because here's the other gross thing
about what they're doing in this clip
and it's intentional folks this is
[__] intentional you see this white
woman railing to a bunch of white people
watching this white privileged Network
and this white privilege show about how
whites in Rural America are being taught
about black people's plight and
institutional racism all the while down
at the bottom of the screen they
this is crazy to me Ron DeSantis
yesterday stood in front of a microphone
and said what does queer Theory have to
do with African-American study well what
in the hell does transgender ideology at
the bottom of this screen you see it
right here
what the hell does that have to do with
it huh if queer Theory doesn't why does
that the reason why is because they want
white people to believe that it's all
the Democrat demons all the Democrat
demons the transgenders the LGBT Keys
the blacks the the the the Mexicans that
they want you to believe that they're
the demons they're coming after your
privilege they're coming after your rule
community and they're going to teach you
how to be black or they're going to
teach you how to be a person of color or
they're going to teach you how to be
transgender this is all [__] just
Insanity absolute Insanity that Rhonda
santis yesterday is saying the exact
opposite of how they're framing it up
here on the screen it's ridiculous but
you know expect them to not be
Hypocrites especially racist ones listen
to this because that's the only voting
block that liberals do not have yep
exactly that's why they want to
brainwash them like for instance I just
heard of a girl wanting to be a cat near
my hometown in Ohio and she's like suing
her parents and the school so she can be
a cat
so also in the same segment they equate
black people and transgender people with
animals
of course they want to strip them of
their humanity and by tying it to that
hey we can't let these animals in White
America white rule America that is what
they're [__] saying it's what they're
saying it's not it's not complicated and
the white people watching this [__] in
rule America the racist the bigots
understand every single dog whistle they
know exactly what these people are
saying because their racist bias that's
what it's intended for that's who it is
on a white platter I'm almost certain
that
the story that he's talking about if I
remember correctly it's from like
is this the cat litter box story yeah
yeah
this is
almost honestly to the day uh at least
according to this NBC article January
25th 2022 which is about this cat litter
story right so it's the but here's the
thing the superintendent debunked this
claim of litter boxes being in schools
for students who identify as cats Joe
Rogan [__] pushed on his podcast it
was debunked
this is just more of the same [__]
so the idea that they're like oh I heard
this kid was suing the school because
they wanted to identify as a cat no no
no no never happened not gonna happen
not a real thing that is totally not
true and has been debunked again and
again and again and we are one year
later and just like the [__] M Ms
they are reusing the same type of woke
[__] to complain about stuff
yesterday they were talking about
[__] Xbox power save mode tomorrow
they're going to talk about I don't know
[__] door hinges yeah it is gastos
[__] I honestly think it's 808 or
whatever they're gonna complain about
the the most ridiculous things and I say
as a joke door hinges because they're
gonna be like oh
I just I guarantee it's going to be
something so so dumb so trivial so
absolutely irrelevant that they will
complain about something that actually
benefits them in society to only [__]
about it
just like they do with everything else
and once it gets removed and once they
make a bunch of noise and say oh no we
shouldn't have this thing and then there
then later they go oh it'd be really
great if I had this thing
let's see
and that's another example that is
another perfect example prime example of
right you know from the very so they're
they're buying this thing you said yeah
yeah go so click the W Restaurants
that's yeah yeah
is that is that an actual yeah they they
they're typically like get Oasis
okay that's well that into one I've been
to one no I I won an airport
I've uh there's still a few a W's here
in Missouri
um that that are starting I was I was
questioning rather that's the real
account or not
um it's obviously this is obviously a
parody when I show it to you the
audience will realize
um that this is a parody
um and they're
I I want to I told the audience that I
think they were watching a w must have
been watching the other day
um because we were like we were like hey
this is all [__] this is all a joke
yeah
and this one's even more obvious than
the Eminem thing I mean when you have a
[__] character that's a bear and
jeans well I I actually think he's
always been in jeans yeah yeah I I think
he's always been yeah I don't I think
this is all [__] like they're
actually lying in this statement that he
didn't have genes I'm not sure and you
can look it up what's the name of the
spokespare here uh Rudy Rudy the great
root beer root beer Rudy the great root
bear hmm
um so a w root beer must have been
listening oh no no no no he didn't have
pants he didn't have pants he didn't
have pants can you can you give me a
picture and um yeah yeah uh and and
we'll we'll show that after um we talk
about the the bit here because this is
the bit and they're baiting the right
wing again A W again must have been
listening to us the other day and saw
our blueprint of how to bait the right
wing and get a free commercial so here
you go a w I don't know if you're uh
looking for sponsors here's a [__]
free ad for you at a w root beer is
excellent by the way and the restaurant
is great too they got great Burgers
there and Fries
um if you like fast food which I do I
haven't been to one in years because I
typically only saw in the midwest when I
would do road trips it isn't the main it
is but I can't remember man Atlanta
airport I forget which airport but there
wasn't there was an A W and I was like
so it's kind of like a novelty in an
airport like a like a Cinnabon or
something yeah yeah like you don't see
them very often and I've only seen it
once yeah well so here's the statement
from a w All-American food
um it says America let's talk have you
heard that before in a statement like
this weird it's kind of funny it's
almost like the other one was parody and
they're parroting the parody yeah it
says since 1963 Rudy the great root bear
has been our beloved spokespare oh this
has the same tone as another statement
that the left and the right was outraged
about the other day yep it's almost like
we pointed it out now a W's following
suit they say they're going to say we
knew people would notice because he's
literally a six foot tall bear this is
so funny yeah he's just six it's a
[__] cartoon he's not six foot he's
two inches on the goddamn anyways
um wearing an orange sweater
but now we get it even a mascots lacking
of pants can be polarizing it's almost
like they just copied the um the M M's
yeah I mean you don't yeah it's honestly
it's you just have to have those
keywords America let's talk right but
now we get it like those just those two
idea to mock the idea that this is the
real thing a six foot tall bear and they
even they even if you go to the comments
after this uh because you'll see the
article that Fox News article and then
you'll see the comments and people like
is this real oh my God so they go on to
say therefore we have decided that Rudy
will wear jeans going forward they're
gonna put some pants on this
[__] uh not because his cartoon
wiener is hanging out apparently which I
don't think they act did they actually
draw the wiener on him oh yeah dude it's
[__] huge oh it's huge it's new I
mean it's bigger than Hunter Biden's I
was just gonna say it's pretty on par
with Hunter by today it's like it's like
slightly bigger
uh not to worry though he will remain
our official spokespare after all he is
unbearably cute and impossible to
replace
um this is all obvious jokes and
pointing to the Eminem thing that's
jokes we are confident Rudy
which is kind of funny Rudy Giuliani
Rudy the great anyways uh we'll continue
to Champion good food and good times for
many years to come now in denim now my
question is how do we know this is denim
really can they prove it to us that this
is an actual denim yeah I would need to
source that material to know I know
again the reason why we bring this up is
because uh we actually said the other
day that it was all of a [__] gag
yeah the Eminem thing and the right wing
bought it the right wing bought it and
the left wing bought it people were like
cowards you guys are cowards you're
caving and every article I've seen and I
have what was that that should be
released tomorrow that breaks down Fox
News and the right wing obsession with
candy and wanting to have them with
dicks and [__] it's [__] weird
but the idea
that uh
that they get so upset over something so
[__] dumb and buy into it and it goes
for the left wing too people got so
upset the right wing was like oh yeah
yeah we canceled that [__] Eminem
well that's crazy oh my God and it's all
it's all a setup for a Super Bowl
commercial but here is Rudy the great
root bear
um in his and is formerly uh his attire
he has a orange hat orange sweater she's
got like a little Beret right like a
little orange Beret kind of thing he's
drinking a big mug of root beer now for
all you folks out there that don't want
to see this bear wiener
um hold your
hold your eyes shut because here we go
um this is this is Rudy the great root
bear without pants oh wait oh oh okay he
doesn't have genitalia maybe that's why
the right might must be so uh offended
by this is because Rudy now has pants to
cover up what they now what now I assume
I'm surprised is genitalia in the pants
right I'm surprised that they aren't
saying whoa whoa Rudy's a boy but
doesn't have a penis
like that's that's the logic that would
be like wait wait wait how does this
cartoon bear not have an anatomically
correct penis well that's why they would
be it's weird Tony it is so weird this
this is so dumb that we have to that we
have to have this conversation when it
it's we talk about political commentary
and social commentary here and we have
to do this because the right wing buys
this stupid [__] and while the left wing
too but here is um so they really so
just for everyone knows they released
this yesterday
right and they are now coming back to
comment on [__] two two hours ago yeah
so this is right this is like me coming
back with my my trump statements and
people like is this a joke I can't tell
and I go yeah I don't know so I ate
nabia restaurants uh releases an
official statement it is now a good time
to mention this is a joke
sweats I this is
I can't even believe they have to put
this tweet there that this is a joke
yeah because you know obviously they
were poking fun at the Eminem thing in
the right wing getting all butt hurt and
the left wing for that matter getting
all butt hurt about the obvious satire
that was the Eminem statement
um that was just bait for the right wing
but
um and and this person post here Fox
News didn't get the joke
um so they actually played this which is
not surprising after yesterday the clip
we showed about them freaking out that
Xbox has a feature that I don't know
makes it to where it costs less in your
electric bill to play Xbox I don't get
it how they didn't see that but I mean
these people don't I'm telling you
tomorrow they're the college prep
courses are are taught to high school
students not first graders but they're
gonna tomorrow you know they're gonna be
like why do we even have steering wheels
on these cars they're gonna say some
dumb [__] and they're gonna see people
these steering wheels are getting woke
gave Santa have you seen the steering
wheels they're in my way they're still
woke that when you actually have an
accident a feminist a feminist [__]
pillow comes out of it to save your life
dude it is it is filled oh my God put my
face and it's and it's a huge huge hit
to the face with estrogen yeah it's just
it's just to take away your masculinity
that's all it is is it's just to take
away your masculinity that airbag thing
it's a woke airbag it's a woke steering
wheel and we need to stop it and you
know who made it who was China probably
in a lab China China which honestly Joe
Biden made money off the Chinese airbags
in your Wilkes steering wheels that's
this doesn't sound like a far off it's
not too crazy because you're like oh
yeah that car was made in China right
that airbag was made in China it's in a
world and then someone's gonna be like
oh and it's obviously Joe Biden's fault
any profited from it yeah yeah yeah and
it was all inspired by Hunter Biden's
the laptop from hell has the evidence of
the Wilkes steering wheels colluding
with Janet mcjuben money and for your
steering wheels to be woken ruining
Society I mean this is it sounds like a
thing that they would do it's it's
totally possible if we see it on the
news in the next week you know where you
heard it first you're right well they
might be watching and getting ideas from
us probably I think they are Joe
Scarborough I'm going to show it to you
here in a second because we're going to
get into this documents thing the whole
apples and versus orange orange here um
but Joe Joe Scarborough is on to me and
on to us because as soon as Merrick
Garland uh appointed the special counsel
we were saying the exact same thing that
it finally now Joe Scarborough is
getting to he's finally getting there
realizing what is happening and why it
is important that the special counselor
was appointed in the in the Biden case
and how it destroys Republicans
narrative they didn't see it then and
freaking out but now they finally see
what we were talking about because it's
only common sense now also common sense
is that George Santos is a [__] liar
that's common sense I like these I like
these chase videos that they do oh
they're great I mean oh yeah I've got an
idea for one but I I won't uh I won't
say it again because I don't want
somebody taking the idea because it
happened before it's happened multiple
times in our ideas they're watching
they're stealing art ideas I know where
all the good ideas come from they come
from here at the Tony Michaels podcast
but let's watch as um George Santos uh
is running from the and he's not really
running from the media he just he's
nowhere else right yeah I mean he he
there's a it's a there's a there's a
common uh statement that he makes he
goes guys I need room I need room I need
space to I need space can you get out of
the way it's like they don't owe you
[__] man you lied to everyone you lost
any privilege to get [__] space right
as soon as you've as soon as you lied
about your grandparents being the
Holocaust you being Jewish your mom
dying in 9 11. what didn't he lie about
though really I honestly don't know I
honestly don't even know if George
Santos knows who George Santos is
probably not probably not
um well let's let's watch this clip and
I think uh the most important thing here
to remember is that
George Santos again it's not special
he's a republican this is what
Republicans do they lie cheat steal the
grift that's the whole point of their
that's their whole brand he's just on
brand the problem is as George Santos
tried to get every single lie and every
single bio Republican thing that they do
and he was really shitty at it but let's
watch
every campaign does hire fiduciary what
he's saying the problem is the lie here
with um Anthony divulder excuse me
um um
dabrowsky no Santos
um I don't know I can't Georgie Bear
yeah I can't keep up with all the names
here but um Santos here representative
George Santos if that is his name uh is
not
um saying is that he hired someone and
that they can when you hire someone you
can tell them how to do something so
he's saying I instructed and hired
someone to do something which I
again we're gonna find out that's why
they're asking him these questions
because he there's gonna be evidence of
this guy
[__] lying about how he hired someone
and didn't order him to do this I mean
it's it's just on and on with this guy I
I honestly I I give him a lot of credit
about this these chase videos because I
don't know if I'd want to deal with it
honestly and and and I tweeted out that
this this clip I bet Donald Trump is
[__] infuriated about about Santos
yeah because Donald Trump is the OG
Santos and Donald Trump would love to
have this attention you remember when he
was getting on the [__] helicopter
and he'd come out and they'd [__] you
know be asked he'd love that he well you
know he loved it so much that I'm sure
if you've looked online you'd find the
videos where he just like walks around
the White House along for them yeah he's
like they'll be here any minute now he's
gonna pay attention to me yeah
but yeah I mean
honestly George Santos he
I'll give him credit
in the fact that he
you know he's gotten to a point where
everyone's like wow okay you've
literally lied about every single
literally every single aspect of your
life where like and more than one lie on
each aspect too yeah it's not like he
picked out one line stuck with it like
he'll tell three or four lines about one
thing exactly and here's the thing like
George Santos has you know I've said it
before like it's like he went through a
buffet line right and it's like a la
carte and he's like oh I'll take that
and I'll take that and I'll take that
and it's a republican live and he was
like I'll do that because what people
need to realize is that George Santos in
New York's Third District okay
there are a lot of people okay first off
New York there is not one event that
resonates more than 9 11. all right and
there's a lot of people from I wonder
what it could be about that event that's
crazy you know crazy and there's a lot
of people from New York's third that uh
that have family members or know people
that were lost in 9 11. so that's that
that really hits the heartstrings right
so George Santos looks at this and says
oh well how better how best can I
connect with these people huh well I'll
just say my mom [__] died in the
south tower on 9 11. and then you find
out no she was actually in Brazil and
didn't come over until 2003 according to
immigration papers so that's just one
thing or or the idea that he lied about
getting coveted as a way to resonate as
a uh sympathy vote right turns out he
didn't have covet right because he was
on he was he said he was one of one of
the first people in New York to have
covet and go to the hospital but then
like four days later or five days later
after he was diagnosed with covid he was
totally fine healthy on a podcast able
to talk no problem you know he said he
had a brain tumor it's not a tumor all
of these lies all of these lies
stealing the money from a a veteran it
does not stop and here's the thing you
know we keep we keep asking ourselves
like is this it right like is did we get
most of it like no because oh [__] no
not at all because it keeps like he
didn't he didn't just start lying when
he ran for congress yeah this guy's been
doing this [__] for years because
remember he ran he ran in 2020 he was
married to a woman got divorced two
weeks before he also lied about the fact
that he was so he was married to this
woman he was sending out wedding Hammer
Anthony divulder uh yes and he was was
married to a woman and at the same time
was sending out wedding invitations uh
after getting engaged to his boyfriend
and then when reporters talk to the
boyfriend they're like okay first off
never a thing that was never gonna
happen because there was never an
engagement so you're saying so you're
saying the invitations were a lie
no no he actually posted on Facebook and
said like we you know we're probably
we're proud to announce whatever this
[__] is but the the then boyfriend
was like no it was all lie there was
never gonna be a party because I
continuously denied and rejected his
proposals and in a textbook that's what
I'm saying is the Merit that oh yeah
there was going to be a wedding with him
and this person
the quote that he gave a reporter his
then boyfriend was like I rejected him
three times there was never gonna be a
party or anything in regards to it so
George Santos you know again oh I've
been gay my whole life you've been
married you were married right before
you ran for for congress in 2020 when
you lost and then you went to a stop to
steal rally and claimed that you
were victim uh number one of voter fraud
and that they had just taken votes in
the middle of the night that's where he
stole a scarf right that is and then and
that's the same roommate that he had for
a few months that revealed to Anderson
Cooper on CNN that he went under Anthony
or Anthony zabrovsky uh when he made his
gofundme's for his uh dog charity scam
right so there's it's just like one
thing one thing after another it's it's
all it's crazy I know there's more
steaming [__] underneath this big pile
of [__] that is George Santos but let's
watch the rest of this video and then I
want to get into the apples versus
orange here yeah let's let's watch the
rest of uh Santos running away from the
media what was the source of your funds
sir what was the source of that money
sir why can't you divulge why can't you
divulge with the source of the money
Congressman santosio what what can you
say about the source of that money
providers
you're taking in great um requests and
we're reviewing stuff we're getting a
lot of requests for academy uh for the
Military Academy so I'm pretty excited
about the chopper too why did you file a
police
laughs
why did you why did you file a police
report about your assassination attempt
that allegedly happened
Congressman do you do you Congressman
Congressman Congressman do you know
if anyone is um keeping track
okay
he's told almost as many lines almost as
many lines as Donald Trump almost not
quite he's not quite there he's working
on it though he's working on it
I mean he's he is he is working so hard
to uh assassination attempt yeah yeah
[__] is wrong with his gay so back in
2021 he said that uh because it was let
me see if I can find the clip it was on
Rachel Maddow
um and they covered it but basically in
2021 he said that uh there was an
assassination attempt and they tried to
steal his [__] shoes and [__] it's a
oh my God it's too good man no lies I'm
in here I'll give I'll give him some
credit the lies are somewhat creative uh
They Don't Really check out because
typically when you tell a lie for the
people who's watching okay uh when you
tell a lie maybe it's a good kind of I
don't know uh method or strategy to have
some truth in the LIE well the other
thing too is when you tell lies it's
like you shouldn't have it recorded I
don't know like on the open internet for
everyone to see and find like I I don't
know that might be a good idea to deny
it might to not be on video uh calling
yourself Anthony devolder when now your
Congressman George Santos right or have
multiple accounts you know under
different names doing different things
you know defrauding people claiming
you're this person blah blah blah might
help I found I sent you the clip if you
want to yeah what's this clip so this is
the this is the Rachel Rachel Maddow uh
clip from the show that shows him
um talking about
being assassinated or attempting to be
so this is it this is I'm just gonna
play the game because if I play Rachel
they're gonna bang us on uh yeah on
YouTube bangus or knock us which one
should I say I mean I you know I I don't
know yeah you know I'm trying to be
politically incorrect here today yeah
okay let's watch the um
George Santos um being assassinated I
mean claiming he was being assassinated
yeah yeah yeah not actually assassinated
in an interview with a Brazilian podcast
uh the podcast is called radio novello
apresenta forgive my pronunciation radio
novello a presenta they shared this
video from the interview exclusively
with us uh so you won't see this
anywhere else but I want you to see it
um in this interview then Congressman
elect George Santos is speaking with the
hosts in Portuguese so we have subtitled
it he starts off talking about an
alleged Act of vandalism which he says
was targeted at him simply because he's
a Republican but then in the midst of
that he says oh also someone tried to
murder him
so why would he be speaking Portuguese
Gabe Sanchez is there a reason I mean
other than the person on the other end
is Portuguese obviously but right right
uh well you know because he's from
Brazil you know even though he said he
grew up in a basement in New York yeah I
thought yeah
I've seen and his mom died in the South
Tower in 9 11. and he was a non-drag
performer and he wasn't he didn't prefer
to drag in 2000. he was just it's
non-drag yeah non-drag it was it was
drag-ish Ish yeah
uh he's kind of ish you know what I mean
like all around he's an ish okay let's
let's see what he says uh in Portuguese
again the subtitles will try to give you
what he says uh with the subtitles
okay so he says on January 2021 my home
was vandalized my husband and I had gone
to new and New Year's Eve party now this
husband is that the one that he claiming
is gonna marry uh no I don't believe
that oh this is a different so he's
actually he was actually married to he
did have a husband or I thought he had a
wife we had a wife okay and then he uh
yeah because the way was the
announcement that went out for George
Sanchez is Pedro and I decided to join
our toothbrushes
right but according according to this
because it was like join us Sunday or
Sunday November 23rd at 8 30 p.m at La
bonus soup in Manhattan
so my guess is just in this first
statement that he's saying again it's in
Portuguese so I'm reading the subtitles
in January 2021 my home was vandalized
that's probably a lie
um my husband and I that's probably a
lie I don't know if he was married to
this guy or not or who he's claiming
here had gone to a New Year's Eve party
which that's probably also a lie I would
imagine but here's the oh the other
thing I do want to mention about the
husband so in this in this article that
was mentioning about this um you know
engagement fake engagement thing
um
so yeah
okay so it says although Santos's 2022
campaign bio mentioned the husband who
according to Santos was living with him
and their four dogs in Long Island the
aspiring public servant kept his
previous marriage to a woman's okay but
I don't know if this is the same dude so
they actually got divorced so he wasn't
married they got divorced okay two weeks
before he filed the official paperwork
to launch his 2020 campaign he divorced
the woman or the man
uh the woman okay and then he married
and then he got married to his husband
and they got married to a husband and
he's and he's currently married
well I guess so I'm I'm just I I mean I
don't honestly don't I'm just trying to
figure out what lie he which lie he's
telling here you know what I mean I
don't know which one I mean the guy the
guy is a pathological liar right and if
you think you know something you don't
when it comes to George Santos and when
you do realize that something
something that he said was a lie then
you revealed something else to be true
then you find out that there's some lie
that tries to cover for that right I
just want to point out though the fact
that George Santos
um because I don't give a [__] who he
marries his [__] business but I just
want to point out that um he's using
other human beings uh ex people he I
mean I I don't know I assume if you're
gonna marry someone you would you would
probably claim to love them even if you
didn't you'd claim it probably
um he's using him in his little Pawn
game here for all his lies which is kind
of gross and sick and vile but you know
what it reminds me of someone there's a
guy who ran in 2016 who was who who was
married three times and each time he
married a new wife it was the it was the
it was the woman he cheated on his
former wife with
classic kind of funny well I mean he
didn't he didn't get stormy but you know
he got the other ones who [__] hated
themselves right it's probably because
uh stormy saw him for the small mushroom
he was okay let's let's continue here
with the George Santos I was almost
assassinated why uh uh
[Music]
um
[Applause]
okay so there it is so he's claiming
somehow that January 2021 they were
vandalized because they were a New
Year's Eve party I had something to do
with Florida in December 2020 uh
experienced vandalism there I guess uh
maybe that's where he was I guess I
don't know
he's saying down to Florida and then
they vandalized it while they were in
Florida I guess and he says at the end
here he claims we have already suffered
an attempt on my life an assassination
tip now you got to remember this is this
is
um
December 2020 folks this is not 2022
during the midterms yeah no one knew who
this well no one knows who he is now
really right right and we're trying to
figure that out I guess but no one knew
who he was to to um put an assassination
attempt on him yeah no he was a nobody
and uh but he's saying this he's saying
this just just um
um well yeah
this is the same this is the same type
of stuff that you know when you're like
oh they committed voter fraud and they
they they stuffed the ballots and it was
all against me in the middle of the
night and blah blah all that [__]
I'm the victim and blah blah blah sounds
really trumpian it sounds sounds very
trumpy okay let's let's see if he says
anything else about this assassination
attempt oh hey
okay there it is there's the evidence of
the LIE he says a threatening letter
having to have the police a police
escort standing in front of my house and
there's no police report because I would
bet I would almost bet keep saying just
that there was no way that a police
department would give you a police
escort if you didn't file a report for
an assassination that would just be my I
don't know wild guess
that when he when he tells the wild
story that he has an assassination temp
and then the police are escorting him
but the police have no [__] record of
of of any kind of complaint being filed
about a threat on his life seems kind of
yeah I don't know like he's horrible at
lying I mean even he's a republican he
even claimed that
uh he had shoes stolen off his feet
wait like when he's walking just like in
this interview you know in the mid he
said he goes Fifth Avenue and that
wasn't the worst of it nobody did
anything nobody did anything complaining
about how he was a victim of multiple
crimes you know this is the same guy
because this because the other thing too
is we've talked about on the show
multiple multiple times
how white people don't suffer from
actual oppression so what they do is
they co-opt it and they try to make new
things and how they're the victim George
Santos is no different this guy says
well how do people how do people relate
right what do what do people really
cling on to okay how do I get these
people love me if my mom died in 9 11.
right they would love me if I had covet
they would love me with my mom would be
if I helped the veteran save his dog
which I did and I stole the money right
they would love me if I was a victim of
an assassination attempt but again he's
a nobody that nobody cares about and the
only reason people care about him is
that he lied and now people are taking
an interest because everything he said
has been a complete lie he's a
pathological liar he's a republican Gabe
Sanchez this he wanted to be famous and
now he's Infamous no he's a republican
speaking of scumbag lying Republicans
and we got Cancun Crews here and we're
gonna move to the documents Dollar Store
Wolverine story yeah we're gonna we're
gonna give the the audience why when we
said the special counsel assigned to the
Biden documents case was a good thing
and the right was going to lose their
narrative I did not know at the time
that Mike Pence and his the fly on his
head would enter the chat
um but I'm predicting today that
Senators like Ted Cruz will enter the
chat soon where he's going to be known
to have documents with classified
markings in places that he shouldn't
have them yeah I know and I know the
exact response I know the exact response
that they'll have if they come for those
documents from sitting Senators previous
Senators they're going to say the FBI
the tyrannical government is now kicking
down your door and it's talking about
the classified documents okay they're
not like hey I should have had these
classified documents or or even I didn't
even know I had these classified
documents
not that I should have had them or not
well because Ted Cruz I almost bet Ted
Cruz in his home in Texas and at his
home in Washington DC in unsecure areas
has inadvertently I'm not saying it's
it's intentional he inadvertently has
documents that have classified markings
on them for sure he's a United States
Senator it's gonna happen that's it that
is gonna happen in this case and I
almost I almost guarantee every single
one of these Senators that go before and
use this excuse that Biden was a Senator
when some of these documents thrown are
gonna if I can have documents and that's
why they're gonna be like the FBI even
though it has nothing to do with normal
citizens they're gonna be like if they
can do that to me if they can kick down
my door looking for these classified
documents that I just complained that
Biden had and that it was worse than
Trump right even though I had classified
documents at my house they're going to
say if the FBI can come to my home and
kick down my door and in a tyrannical
fashion take my stuff without any
permission if they can do that to me oh
imagine what they can do to you yeah
normal
citizen if you had a classified document
Mark classified and you had it in an
unsecure location they would do the same
to yeah they would absolutely I should
probably go check my closets to make
sure I don't have classifieds probably
you should yeah I mean sorrow sends us a
lot of stuff so yeah I don't read
through it all I just kind of put it off
to the side for tax season but you know
sticking in there and buying well I mean
you know there's a lot of checks and a
lot of payments are coming from the
antifa antifa club that is George Soros
is the head of let's listen to Cancun
Crews here this is hilarious I I can't
even believe that Kudlow here's like oh
yeah this is going to be great this is
going to be great we're gonna
we're gonna make this look like Mike
Pence is awesome and Joe Biden sucks
this is horrible they did they didn't
even practice this Gabe Sanchez not once
watch this then this shifts for
political problem to a very serious
problem of criminal liability and and
Major Crimes and so the FBI needs to
search the University of Delaware
archives and they need to search Hunter
Biden's home and business address so now
the FBI is the good guys right yeah when
they're searching Joe Biden stuff and
underbites they're the good guys not we
do not want to defund yeah the FBI that
will search Tony can you can you tell me
has the FBI changed uh like leadership
at all since it all started or even
since the Trump Administration feels
like it feels like they're their guy
that they're complaining about the FBI
searching him almost it almost feels
like he probably appointed the guy who's
the head of the FBI oh it almost feels
like that's probably the case I'm not
sure we'd really have to try to figure
that out and do our own research
research I'm sure but listen this gets
oh this is this is Juicy especially when
cut low he must be drunk here he's got
to be drunk because he asked a question
that makes Ted Cruz look like a [__]
fool which I mean it's not hard to do
but let's watch
um just as an addendum to this the news
came out today I'm sure you saw that
former vice president Mike Pence a
friend of both of ours he's found some
classified documents uh I think at his
home in Indiana not in his office uh
what do you make of that is this
different from the Biden story does this
complicate the story are we going to
continue the bull market and special
councils I'd rather have a bull market
in stocks than in special councils how
do you see at Santa Cruz I bet what
Senator Cruz is going to say here is
that the FBI better go to Mike Pence's
residence and his office and they better
search right now because there's
Criminal Intent because because a former
vice president has possession of what
his documents that are marked have
classified markings I almost I mean
that's not what he's going to say I mean
I think he's going to say that if Biden
got a special counsel and Trump got a
special counsel then Mike Pence should
definitely get a special counsel right I
tell you what he does is he licks
Trump's balls that's what he did that's
what he is
oh wow sloppy ASMR well here's the thing
he has he he has they have to they have
to do this stupid thing with uh the
comparison of Pence and Biden which oh
yeah
Trump yeah and and the the mainstream
media because I'm going to show you a
[__] click but Joe Scarborough
realizing this in real time it seems but
we realize this as soon as it happened
as soon as the special counsel was
announced for the Joe Biden case I knew
this was going to strip away their
narrative that Trump did nothing and
there's nothing there to see but watch
this stupid [__] that he does because
the question Larry Kudlow just asked him
is hey so it's all criminal when Joe
Biden does it but what if Mike Pence did
it which we found out yesterday he did
do it so what is it Chris
Oh look The Mike Pence story it's still
early uh you know Mike Pence and as you
noted he is a good friend he's a good
man he's explained where these came from
oh oh wow oh well dick Grease
we'll take his word for it never mind
he's a good dude and he explained it
already that should be enough let's see
Tony I don't know what we're still
talking about I don't know he just said
yeah that Mike Pence explained it so
that's fine that's good enough for me
man Mike Pence is such a good man he he
won't even allow himself in a room with
a woman alone because he doesn't trust
himself apparently or mother doesn't
trust him Wow
Let's be clear
he can't be in another room because
mother doesn't approve of it but let's
be real about this there is probably
well no they're probably some women but
there's definitely not a majority of
women it's a very very even one number
that would even even [__] want to
touch the skin or the hair listen it had
to fly I would say I would say that the
majority of women in this country Not
only would not want to be in this uh
alone with him in the same room but in a
room with a bunch of people with yeah
the majority would not even want to be
in a room can you imagine getting just
like a like one of those blank stares or
him or he's like
because he he makes he makes let me let
me assure you Gabe Sanchez takers here
makes a really remember this guy was the
solicitor Junior of Texas he has
presented cases before The Supreme Court
and he was not ready for this and he
makes he makes a really good case here
for Mike Pence wink let's launch is that
in packing up the vice presidential
offices oh yeah that there were a couple
of papers oh no [__] that were
inadvertently oh no kidding classified
materials oh my God that was a mistake
but there's no reason uh to think about
anything but yeah no kidding that is
very different from what Joe Biden Joe
Biden
it's got there and in particular
he has given no explanation as to how he
has documents from his time in the
Senate listen there it is there's the
sticking point that they want because
I'm going to show you a video here of
Elise stephanic and and get this is a
sitting United States Senator saying
this [__]
on Larry Kellow show last night or
yesterday afternoon about this the
difference between Apples and the orange
I mean there's a bit I don't know about
you but the difference is so big you
could I mean it's like as big as the Gap
in the Grand Canyon dude it's [__]
massive there is there is so much that's
different that's so much that's
different that my what about is and will
stand up to any facts oh my God that
come at it well I mean again they're
clinging onto the senator thing which I
think is a total mistake for them
um again it's going to steal away their
narrative and I'm going to show you a
clip of Joe Scarborough at least
stefanik by the way yeah and this comes
back to George Santos at least stefanik
even after news broke and even after
people were leaving George Santos's like
team at least a phonic was there happily
finding people to replace those AIDS and
those other people within his like team
yeah because they needed the vote to get
Kevin McCarthy across the line
I mean not that we didn't already know
she's a piece of garbage and listen to
this is this is not very long
um and she goes into the explanation and
Gabe Sanchez she not only makes the same
argument Ted Cruz she does a wildly
better job not okay we're doing let's
watch
in the case of Vice President Mike Pence
God damn that's really that's really low
isn't it yeah yeah let me see if I can
increase the volume God damn it
she's it's it's C-SPAN yeah see these
C-SPAN Clips are just not some men some
are bangers and some are not they just
uh let's see let me see if I can adjust
the okay let's see if this works better
no no no still really low
documents going
a long-standing national security threat
setting aside the very important fact
that Hunter Biden also had access and
used as his home address where those
classified documents were improperly and
illegally stored that's because Hunter
Biden lived there you [__] idiot so
yeah this this whole thing well yeah
okay well the whole thing is to to to
get the hunter Biden lamped up in the
story right yeah like that's the whole
key here because they know the Q Anon
dark web The Conspiracy Theory they know
if that if they say the buzzword hunter
Biden in the documents case oh well that
makes it so much different I can't
believe that Joe Biden who is Hunter
Biden's dad that that Hunter Biden would
live at his house for some period as his
permanent residence oh my God who would
have thought who would think who who
would have oh my God it's almost like if
Mike Pence had a child and Nate lived at
his house and used his house as
permanent that would be such a scandal
yeah it's crazy stupid and it's also
even crazier that Joe Biden doesn't have
visitor logs to his home that is he
doesn't he doesn't ask people to sign a
guest book look you have a guest book
right I have a guest book at my house
yeah I when I when I have people come
over I I have that they they there's a
little like when you clock in at work
you know right a little time card I have
them clock in at that time yeah they
sign they sign their name they put their
social security number and they also
give me their thumb print and their
index finger this is all antifa process
this is all the way that it's done duh
and here's thing the fact that Joe Biden
doesn't follow that protocol and provide
Republicans with a visitor log of his
personal home is [__] [__] let me
ask him I almost bet
that if you get one of these
chuckleheads that are calling for the um
the visitor logs of someone's private
home are going to be asked are you going
to ask for the visitor logs of Mike
Pence's private home and any other day
oh my prince he's such a good guy he's
great even flash love him no he's such a
great guy and he's my friend and nothing
to see here because if I say there's
something wrong with Mike Pence there's
definitely going to be something wrong
with uh the Criminal Intent of Donald
Trump and the criminal obstruction of
Donald Trump and that's gonna not uh fit
my narrative speaking of narrative
speaking of narrative Joe Scarborough
Hey Joe I tweeted on you he didn't Hey
Joe Hey Joe Hey Joe
Hey Joe you're catching on
the media is finally catching on to what
we've been talking about for weeks is
that this this documents case them going
on and on and on and lying about Joe
Biden and now having the Mike Pence
enter the chat and and more than likely
within the next few months we're going
to have United States setting United
States senators and former United States
senators who are allies of trump who
have documents that have classified
markings on them this is going to happen
it trusts me it is going to happen
because the Republicans are already
saying this is the difference Joe Biden
was a Senator and I love at least if
Onyx like before I was born
you weren't born before 2008 he was no I
mean like obviously it's it uh it's a
dig you know uh there she's like oh you
know what you know what will be a
[__] good burn if I give my age
without giving my age and say I wasn't
even alive yet when he stole those
documents well you know this is the
whole this is what even people on the
left like Nina Turner do I I want to
start an Internet fight with her so bad
I do I text you yesterday I want to
start an Internet Internet fight where
there's she's like the RNC newcoms
director okay the communication director
at the RNC this is [__] that they say
like oh Joe Biden has been in government
since before I was born like why do you
think he's so good at it yeah why the
[__] how the [__] don't you know the
reason why he's gotten so much [__] done
is because I don't know he's done it
before he's been doing it for a long
time it's almost like he understands
fundamentally how the Senate how the
Congress how the executive branch how it
all works it's almost like it's almost
like he has a lot a lot of experience
doing the thing called I don't know
government like he was a vice president
he was a Senator it's crazy crazy stuff
that he knows this how to get things
done in government what's the link you
sent me here uh I don't know uh no that
was a matter I need to drop for one
minute I'll be right back oh yeah okay
yeah let's let's show this clip from Joe
Scarborough Gabe will rejoin us here
um as um as we go to this Joe
Scarborough this is from Morning Joe
this morning and they're finally
catching on they're finally catching on
that the story of the documents at Joe
Biden's house actually does not help
trump it hurts Trump uh it hurts Trump a
lot
especially as the Biden's knocking or
the excuse me the Trump the pent Jesus
Christ the Pence documents case comes to
light now watch this as Joe realizes
this you know Pence actually only shines
a brighter light on Trump
Biden actually only shines a brighter
light on Trump's illegalities people are
going oh they can't press charges
against yes they can yes they can
because what Mike Pence did and what Joe
Biden did is what law abiding citizens
would do they find classified documents
they immediately contact the authorities
they immediately secure them and they
immediately get them to the doj okay so
Joe Scarborough is coming to the
conclusion here that I came to weeks ago
weeks ago I don't know when was it that
we found out about the binding documents
does anybody know that it was like two
two weeks ago two weeks ago and it was
it feels like a millennia but it was two
weeks ago that we found like January
12th I said that day that day before
before anyone else probably that this
was bad for Donald Trump it's horrible
for Donald Trump horrible and the Mike
Pence thing only makes it worse and
really the Mike Pence thing doesn't make
it worse on on Trump himself it really
makes it really bad on Republicans right
their narrative is smashed up here and
they're gonna smash it up even more by
claiming the difference between Pence
and Biden is Biden used to be a senator
which Mike Pence was a [__]
Congressman folks yeah I don't know if
anyone knows that that [__] was
a congressman before he was a vice
president so this idea that someone in
the legislative branch would I mean I I
just I can't [__] imagine why they
would say because he's a senator only to
project that hey this is going to be
really bad when sinning senators and
former Republican Senators who are
defending this saying [__] like oh this
is so egregious that Joe Baden and
Hunter Biden laptop and dick pics and
Corvettes they say these you know
buzzwords in there well they're going to
have a hard time because what's what's
happening here and yeah we've talked
about on the show before is the idea
that you were like this is good for Joe
Biden because Joe Biden it really it
it's night and day it shows you that
they found these documents and they said
oh we don't we should not have these
documents and then they contacted the
proper you know agencies they contacted
the FBI they can't contact ignara they
did everything they did they did some
more searches they found some more
documents then they were like hey look
just to be safe we're going to hire a
special counsel Republicans are like hey
what's he trying to hide what's he
stealing those documents what's he doing
with that stuff why was it at the Biden
Pen Center why was that at his home
and they're like give me a special
counsel that's not the special counsel
that I wanted God damn it I didn't want
that person that's some [__] and and
you know they're all these things they
want to complain and complain and
complain when you give them the thing
that they want then they complain you
know what they remind me of
somebody who tries to Blackmail somebody
right they're a blackmailer they're like
give me give me ten thousand dollars and
I'll shut up and you give them ten
thousand dollars and the next month they
go give me 15 or 20 000 and you're like
well I just paid you and you go look I'm
not going anywhere I'm gonna keep asking
for money to keep getting what I want or
else I'm gonna expose you and that's
what they're doing this reminds me of
the scene
um from uh Batman uh The Dark Knight
Rises when the guy comes in to um Morgan
oh no The Dark Knight The Dark Knight is
it dark it's the dark The Dark Knight
yeah that's right so he comes into he
comes into Morgan Freeman's character's
office and he's a he's a employee like a
an accountant attorney or something uh
for for Wayne Enterprises and he says I
know who Batman is and I I want this
this and this and Morgan Freeman looks
at him and it's like let me get this
straight
so you want to Blackmail the person who
dresses up as a vigilante and and
pummels people with their bare hands in
the middle of the night this is your
idea of a good idea but it's like you
want to Blackmail the richest man
richest
and the person that you you claim
dresses up as a bat at night and fights
crime and he's like oh well yeah how
about you you just good luck Good Luck
Good Luck Good Luck I think that's good
luck with that uh and good luck to
anyone who's trying to get this gay
um because this is uh news right now
um Joe Biden has given 31 Abram tanks to
uh Ukraine here's here's the uh short
clip from C-SPAN of the announcement
let's listen and today today I'm
announcing that the United States will
be sending 31 Abram tanks to Ukraine the
equivalent of one Ukrainian Battalion
secretary Austin has recommended this
step because it will enhance the
Ukraine's capacity to defend his
territory and Achieve strategic
objectives behavior of tanks are the
most capable tanks in the world they're
also extremely complex to operate and
maintain
so we're also giving Ukraine the parts
and equipment necessary to effectively
sustain these tanks on the battlefield
when we begin we'll begin to train the
Ukrainian troops on these issues of
sustainment logistics and maintenance
soon as possible oh boy I mean do you
really want to mess with the guy who's
going to give Ukraine to beat the [__]
out of Putin 31 Abram tanks and not just
give them tanks but give them the
equipment the parts and all the
necessary Essentials to to actually
[__] smash up Russia's Army think
about this the the president Ukraine has
been calling for this for months to get
these tanks and we're giving them a
whole Battalion of tanks and and it's
it's not it's it's
it's absolutely
we are saying unequivocally
in our in our democracy that Sovereign
democracies around the world should get
the chance to defend themselves from
authoritarians who want to take their
Sovereign democracy away from them
and Putin is a [__] authoritarian
murderous dictator and he's a war
criminal and the Biden Administration
the defense department is doing
something about it not just not just for
us not just for the American people but
this is for democracy all around the
world to defend it that is the point
here is to defend democracy not do what
Republicans do and try to force people
to be what they want to be we saw this
in the Middle East with the Bush
Doctrine
we are protecting a current democracy
and it's not a perfect democracy it's
not it's not perfect
no democracy really is perfect it's not
designed to be perfect that's actually
the design of it right but they are
sovereign and even their even their
corrupt style democracy in Ukraine those
citizens believe that it's worth
fighting for Worth Dying For so much so
that they're willing to get into a
battalion of tanks and go fight the
Russians for their country yeah it's
it's I mean and and also it really comes
back to this fact of you know again you
know they call they say the president of
the United States is the freedom the the
the leader of the Free World right the
president is the leader of the Free
World and you've got Joe Biden here
saying hey
um
there this whole Russia [__] [__]
with with Putin committing genocide
against innocent ukrainians is not
something we should stand for
Republicans on the other hand want to be
like no no no we should not help anyone
who is against Putin and they have a
real hard time because here's the thing
every stance they take doesn't age well
whether it's gas prices or [__]
Ukraine war or it's these documents
they're going to take a stance
right now that and the best way I can
describe it is a flash in the pan right
because it's meant to be reactionary
it's right now it's in the moment so
it's it's Timely
but it doesn't age well and it doesn't
last it's not like you actually have
something that is that is uh long
serving where you're like oh okay that
was a great stance that you had or that
was a great take or whatever it might be
again it's a flash in the pan it's
reactionary they do it just to own the
lips and [__] own them and get them
and then you find out oh actually you
guys were in the wrong the whole [__]
time you're actually really bad people
and the fact that you're willing to say
oh no no the Russians can kill these
ukrainians and we shouldn't help them
is insane right or they mock him when he
comes to speak and on these very house
floors not only are they bad indecent
people but they're horrible Hypocrites
um we watched as they want to cancel
Eminem and W root beer today and on and
on it goes Xbox because all this wokism
leftism they want to be canceled they
want to cancel that but they don't want
to be canceled Gabe Sanchez because
here's more news Newsmax the trader TV
news network has lost their contract
with DirecTV so you will no longer be
able to watch Newsmax on DirecTV and
they're crying because oh we're being
canceled by the left so let's close
capitalism [__] and they took it to the
house floor today just about an hour ago
Ace and has this um
this clip for us uh dela Rosa I think is
the representative because just so
people know the government didn't drop
the contract right it was a private
company no DirecTV totally is the Deep
state leftist they're woke as [__] oh
the D in DirecTV is deep State got it oh
that's what it is yeah yeah I got it
okay DTV deep
just wanted to make sure I understood
how that worked well let's listen let's
listen to their their tears and enjoy
the Maga tears here because it's
probably I haven't watched this clip but
here it is the house floor I think this
representative De la Rosa uh is gonna
cry about cancel culture when that's all
they want to do
Mr Speaker I rise today to let the
American people know their access to
conservative programming on one of our
nation's conspiracy programs satellite
TV providers is at risk DirecTV one of
my District's largest satellite
providers has threatened to remove
Newsmax from its lineup oh my God we
won't be able to mind [__] all these
people in my how in the hell do I expect
the people in my district to be absolute
deluded if we can't pump the delusion
directly into their ears they'll just
have to go to Fox News which is slightly
less diluted with propaganda but
there might be somebody on there who
gives them an actual right real news
story or fact and they go
Carlos might really [__] them up might
be like oh the documents thing that's
all [__] but let's let's see how she
frames it up here is the left before we
go why why may I ask Newsmax is simply
asked to receive equal compensation for
DirecTV carrying its Channel Through
Carriage freeze though Newsmax has
higher ratings than many other more
liberal stations offered on DirecTV the
satellite provider owned by at T will
not negotiate in good faith with Newsmax
and again I said a t the threat of
conservatives are losing Independent
Media I'm waiting for her to say woke
she surely says TV oh [__] give me a
news channel it's called woke TV uh hey
no let's that do you see you get of all
the good ideas sorry let's hey let's do
a commercial we need a new commercial
anyway yeah all right let's let's make
an idea we'll commit to doing a
commercial for woke TV it's the new I
wrote it down okay all right uh let's
let's listen I I surely she says the
word woke Outlet is is and should real
uh DirecTV not agree to a new Carriage
agreement with Newsmax this appears to
be another victory in the whoops oh
there it is to cancel conservatives and
limit free speech Yes yes she said woke
oh God damn God damn that's crazy uh
representative De La Cruz sorry I
misspoke Dela Cruz De La Cruz from Texas
15th
um in Texas
well people need to realize especially
Republicans is that the idea that a
private company again capitalism a
private company in a free market made
their own choice their company their
choice and they said yeah you know what
we don't want to cover this new station
anymore for whatever reason we're giving
it's our choice it's not that we're you
know it's not that they're creating a
monopoly you know they provide all sorts
of other places they can have Fox News
and whatever other bullshits on there
but they said to Newsmax ah look guys
you might be too crazy for us
we don't yeah they're like look we don't
threatening to drop them is the way that
she said it but look they were like ah
we don't need you we don't want you and
we can choose what we want because we
are a provider of options and we're just
removing one option from the palette
right and so when Republicans don't like
it go to work go to our competitor like
that's the free market you don't like it
you can watch their [__] on on online
well who's your internet right who's
your internet provider to go on to
newsman stream them and stream it you
can download an app on Roku for Newsmax
for all like right here because they
have it there they have a goddamn app on
the phone yeah so you can watch it in
any other place the fact that DirecTV
you know what you know you know what you
know what here's the problem here's the
problem keep changes the the problem
here of of streaming it in a in maybe a
rural area where De La Cruz represents
people is probably because they don't
have the type of Internet that it takes
but you know what's funny about that is
that the Democrats and Joe Biden made it
to where woke internet is coming to
rural areas so that way they can
download their non-woke TV I'm just
saying it just seems kind of funny that
they twist themselves into these
pretzels like this right and this is a
prime example with Newsmax and they're
going I can't even believe that the
agenda for today for the Republican
party in in a representative who
represents Texas's 15th this is what
your representative is doing today going
to the floor of the house and bitching
that a that a private company is in a
private contract with another private
company and they can't come to an
agreement that's why Newsmax is not on
that private company's uh selection and
menu of channels that that is that is
their agenda today yesterday was gas
stoves day before it was Eminem's
tomorrow it will be someone's genitalia
this is the Republican Party George
Santos is not an outlier and Donald
Trump is the OG George Santos one
remember that folks remember that and
when you're talking about the documents
it is apples and the Orange versus the
orange that is what it is and Joe
Scarborough
hey man if you want to come on the show
I'll I'll and really honestly if you
just want to get in a private phone call
I'll tell you exactly what's going to
happen
and I'll let you know and then you go on
your show tomorrow and say the same [__]
and I said today debrief
you have to wait two weeks man you don't
have to wait two weeks to catch up to
what I'm trying to tell you right is the
[__] truth and what's gonna happen I
I know I know it's kind of complicated
but I'll give you the lowdown and then
you can put it on your program you get
oh so many people more watching you even
though it takes you two weeks to [__]
catch up with me Jesus Christ I like you
Joe but God damn God two weeks it took
you two weeks to come to that conclusion
and it took Mike Pence ah [__] everybody
make sure to subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast here on YouTube you're
not going to want to be two weeks behind
by watching people like Joe Scarborough
in the morning you're going to want to
be ahead so make sure to subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast we are here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday for two full hours on YouTube
Twitter and twitch and also simulcasting
from the Midas touch Facebook page so if
you're on Facebook follow our page at
the Tony Michaels download every single
episode on Apple Spotify Google and
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod we need to change this and this this
a graphic we need to put the what was
that everyone did you know there's a
what was that Twitter that you need to
go follow go to Gabe Sanchez's profile
it is on there is it at what was that
show what was that show yeah yeah at
what was that show but it's in it's in
Gabe Sanchez's Twitter profile so go to
I am Gabe Sanchez you can follow the
links back go follow the what was that
because I think you got another one
coming out you just released one but
another one's good yeah just released
one yes two yesterday and then I'm
working on an M M's
Candy Crush outrage yeah uh that'll that
should be coming out candy porn with
candy there's so much candy porn dude
there's a video on there that I don't
think anyone's seen since 2008. whoa
whoa holy holy exclusive holy m m
genitalia this is really gonna dude it's
real right really [__] bizarre
okay everybody same time same place
tomorrow oh I want to thank everyone who
uh has joined the patreon I'm gonna
figure out how to do the shout outs for
everyone who has uh who has done this
shout out uh tier so thank you for
joining my patreon if you if you want to
join go to the Tony michaels.com or go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels I want
to thank you very much and we're going
to figure out how to do those shout outs
for each one of you I'm not sure exactly
I'm gonna do it yet but there's been a
lot of people sign up for that so I
appreciate it very very much thank you
for your support again don't forget to
share this episode and get your friends
and family to subscribe to the YouTube
channel so they can stay two weeks ahead
of the of the of the mainstream media
and Joe Scarborough
at Morning Joe everyone same time same
place tomorrow two weeks ahead of the
mainstream media Surfside [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
foreign
[Music]